-And now I thought
that I'd share
some of my favorite "add a word,
ruin a TV show" responses.
Remember "simmer down now"?
-I love it.
-Bella, you bitch.
[ Laughter ]
Another catch phrase.
-What?
-Cheri, when she was on
the porch,
She would yell, "Bella."
Remember?
What was her character's name?
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-This is old-time stuff.
Ask your folks about this.
-Simmer down now.
-She was like,
"Oh, you best simmer."
[ Light laughter ]
"Simmer down now."
And then --
I remember, she goes --
...wrote those, right?
-Yeah.
-She goes, "Oh.
What --
who is this singer?"
And he goes, "Donna Summer?"
She goes, "What her name say
in the phonebook?"
And he goes, "Summer Donna?"
[ Laughter ]
Simmer down now.
-Come on.
-She is the best.
-It was fun. Come on.
-I love Cheri Oteri.
This first one is from
@AtariKari.
-Oh.
-That's a cool name.
@AtariKari, she says,
"Saved by the Taco Bell."
Oh, there you go.
-Oh.
-Every Saturday night, 2:00am.
-Yeah.
Chicken Gordita Crunch.
-This one is from @janjette.
-Hmm.
-Another cool name.
She says, "Full Outhouse."
Oh, there you go.
[ Laughter ]
"Not the hair --"
-"Don't go in there.
Cut it out."
-This one's from
@WutzzelBuns.
-Mm.
-Higgins, you can't play the
game and be on the show.
-Oh, I can't? Oh.
-@WutzzelBuns says
"The Mickey Mouse Fight Club."
Oh, there you go.
[ Laughter ]
-First -- don't talk about it.
-"First rule of the Mickey --"
no.
[ Laughter ]
[ Quacking ]
"No, no, Donald.
Get over here.
I'll give you the first shot.
Go, Donald, go."
-"What's going on there?"
-"I don't care."
This one is from
@capgraybeard.
-Yeah. @capgraybeard.
-He says, "The A-Hole Team."
[ Laughter ]
-"I love it when a plan
comes together."
[ Laughter ]
-This is from @thethirtiesmom.
She says, "This is Us:
Unfortunately."
-Aw!
[ Laughter ]
-This is it.
-You married it.
-Yep.
This one is from -- at --
from the Emmys.
-Oh.
-From @TheEmmys. The Emmys.
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪
We love the Emmys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Light laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
-The Emmys.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-@TheEmmys, they say,
"Sex and the City Council."
There you go.
I hope they're watching.
This one is from @slfriend79.
She says, "Doctor Who Cares."
[ Laughter, audience ohs ]
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @jmast98.
They say, "Little Trap House
on the Prairie."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Half pint.
Half pint. Half pint.
Two cup, half pint.
Laura.
Nelly.
[ Scattered applause ]
This one's from @TheLapinator.
-Yeah, Lapinator.
-Not sure what that means.
He says "Tom and Jerry
Seinfeld."
-Oh.
[ Light laughter ]
I'd watch that.
-Didn't really get
a big reaction.
-Eh.
-Cutting it from the show.
-What would Tom, what would
Jerry -- what would
Tom and Jerry --
[ Laughter ]
-They'll never see --
It will never see air.
They'll never have -- be famous
or get recognized.
He'll probably will have an
awful day tomorrow at work.
-Oh, man.
[ Audience aws ]
'Cause they didn't care for it.
-'Cause they didn't care for it.
-They judged him.
Yeah.
-They judged him really hard.
[ Light laughter ]
They bullied him.
-What's the deal with that?
What's the deal with
"Tom and Jerry Seinfeld"?
-Let me do it again.
-You think he noticed
something about something?
-Let's tape it again.
Everybody gets a second chance.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-This one is from
@TheLapinator.
-Oh, yeah.
-That's a cool name.
-Love that guy.
-Yeah.
-I like that name.
I get it.
-Yeah.
-Lapinator.
-Like the Terminator
but the Lapinator, sure.
Loved it.
-Don't have to explain it to me.
-Love it.
-I want it.
-Yeah.
-I'll buy it from you if you
don't want to use it.
-Yeah.
I'll give that a dollar.
-Lapinator, he says
"Tom and Jerry Seinfeld."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Didn't see that one coming.
-Yeah.
-Good one, Lapinator.
[ Laughter ]
Come on.
-Here's the last one.
This from @stpeteyontweety.
They say --
[ Laughter ]
"M.A.S.H. Potato."
There you go.
-Yeah, come on.
-There it is, "Tonight Show"
Hashtags.
To check out more of our
favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.